the wrong Missy your movie now airing on
Netflix is number one worldwide I was
telling Robin I love the movie I watched
is this Lauren lapkus who was so funny
in the movie I liken hard to like a Jim
Carrey type of person yeah it's true
yeah there is an audition right cuz you
have to yeah I have to see if there's
something going on she comes in and what
you and Sandler and and and people sit
in a room and work with her yeah that's
the that's the fun part because it was
really more the focus was if I'm the
straight man in it who is going to be
Missy and who's going to be the one that
acts crazy and it's very hard to find
that because it all sort of rides on her
and it's a little bit of a Jim Carrey or
like even back when I did Tommy Boy
where I'm gonna be the straight man
you're gonna be someone who's acting a
little bit as I'm gonna react off them
it's just different arts and by the way
that's what I was thinking about I was
thinking about like all of a sudden this
is good you have great chemistry with
this woman it's like you and Chris
Farley had great chemistry and you would
play straight man to his insanity and
straight man's a fun it's kind of a fun
part and it's it's a little frustrating
because you want on the set to obviously
just do jokes all the time you're out
there they're rolling and you just want
to go crazy and you have to pull it in
and then Rob Schneider's funny and then
Nick Swartz is funny and I'm just gonna
be the one it's sort of traffic copying
the whole all the craziness she killed
it I mean you couldn't have picked a
better person she's just very very funny
and works well with you she was very up
for anything and really worked hard
because she knew like I think her
careers gonna go up David I do I do too
I do too
did you have you seen the movie we watch
of the night it came out it's the only
not fun thing is you can't go to a
theatre and watch as people you can't
even celebrate or get excited and go out
to dinner you're just thinking your
house going hey you get a text number
one movie in the world like a holy [ __ ]
unlike any way back eating my tricks